and the ask of the best screenplay
adaptation is awarded to
emma thompson
[Applause]
[Music]
i think screenplays are about ellipsis
the ellipsis so write everything
and then take out the stuff and take out
as much as you can
until you're right there and just going
there but it's still there somewhere
you could make the whole thing in a way
i suppose
making a film is like adapting a
screenplay
you adapt the whole thing to film
and then you take out the bits that work
well start writing
and then um when you get to the end of
it try
uh throwing out the first three scenes
just
goes into your system it's such a joy
to learn good writing and such a pain
it's
awful learning bad right sometimes you
have to you don't we don't always get to
do
wonderful things and what we want to do
that's not that's not what
this job is like what life is like but
but when it's good
my gosh you're so grateful
and then there's another mysterious
thing that can happen which is by
excising something
not only from a screenplay but also from
a film
this works on both pieces of work um
you can make the juxtaposition of the
two remaining scenes
so much more powerful by leaving
something out i mean
i think screenplays are about ellipsis
the ellipsis so write everything
and then take out the stuff and take out
as much as you can
until you're right the end just going
there but it's still there somewhere
but what's left really
pins out because of what you've taken
away i can't explain why that works
but it sometimes works in performance as
well so it seems to me that
art of all kinds performance are it's
all to do with
energy do you have any tips on keeping
up the momentum in your plot and
avoiding lulls especially if writing a
feature film
or tv series every scene should be
not just there i think somebody gave me
a good tip about this
it's um then
[Music]
because but so at the end of the scene
you go
but it's like the end of a sentence or
the end of a chapter it's
it's really um there should be an event
in every scene really
what's the event that's what mike
nichols always says what's the event
here
but my great friend lindsey duran who
produced um
dead again which is a film i made with
um ken branner
all those years ago she was watching it
and
she thought that's the woman i want to
adapt to jane austen novel
go figure um so she said would you like
to adapt sense of sensibility and i said
well i think i prefer to adapt
persuasion
but i mean i've never adapted anything
why would you
i don't know how so she said would you
be interested i said sure i mean i'll
have a go
uh i will i'll have a go i'll i'll i'll
what will i do i'll go and ask ruth para
jarvala who's a very good screenwriter
what to do
and ruth said dramatize the whole book
and then see which bits work and then
take everything else away and try and
make those bits
then you have to write your bits yes
because where do you where do you begin
and it ends
that's the trick of course because
adaptation is is
both distillation yeah and a kind of
imaginative invention
uh that you you have to use to
create your own skeleton because you
can't put a whole novel onto the screen
it's not possible
because it's like it's like i suppose
with a like piece of sculpture
you know you it that you're that mound
of paper
which is in there somewhere yes i love
the fact that you've bought them
i brought these these are all the drafts
of sense and sensibility and this i
think is the first one
yeah so this mound of paper is just um
[Music]
the novel more or less it's all written
on the back of old script
uh everything in there is and um and
then you wrote it by hand first
yes i write everything by hand yeah
there's there's a few drafts there that
are all handwritten um there's 17
drafts um what i like about the box is
that most people don't see that process
most people's you know you say to them
you've done 17 drafts and they go
oh yeah really and it's all on your
floppy disk or your hard drive yeah
that's
actually a physicalization of it which i
think
five years how do you decide on the best
point in the story to
open the script well start writing
and then um when you get to the end of
it
try uh throwing out the first three
scenes
and see what happens sometimes you'll
come in on a uh
or it'll happen in the edit of the film
because you'll find that
your your first three scenes aren't
necessary
setting up scenes i that's happened to
me a lot actually
um i've written things that i've thought
oh this is great this is really going to
really set it up it's going to be so
dramatic and actually in the end it's
much better to start
very simple and to the point i used to
have violent arguments about the nature
of comedy with
my peers at the time and particularly
with ben elton who was
m you've got to have a joke you've got
to have a joke gotta have a punch line
you've got to have a punch line i said i
don't think you do have to have a punch
line
i think you need a punchline when you're
a boy because
men's jokes are essentially
uh something that goes on and on leading
to
an ejaculation at the end
and women's comedy is
more circular there are little loves
here and then there's a big laugh and
then there's another little laugh
and so i think that our humorous
as it were dna jenna goes hand in hand
with our sexual
um with our orgasmic um
you could make the whole thing in a way
i suppose
making a film is like adapting a
screenplay
you adapt the whole thing to film
and then you take out the bits that work
you can't use the stuff that doesn't
work
you have to cut it and and what's
interesting about that is that you can
shoot something that
has been essential in the screenplay
essential
and then you film it you've adapted it
to film and
you watch it and you think i've seen
that
i can see it so i don't need to have
that scene
and yet everybody up to the point of
filming thought it was going to be an
absolute
vital moment and that's very key isn't
it because you're describing what you've
just seen
so this is the interesting thing so i
suppose
adaptation is is is is indeed
double process you adapt a book to
screenplay and then the
screenplay is adapted into a film this
wonderful producer david livingston said
do you feel like writing a
movie based on george michael wham's
song last christmas and i said not
really
um because i'm not it's not my favorite
christmas song
yeah and um it was a long time ago and
and i listened to it and i thought last
christmas gave me your heart and a very
nice
day you gave it away this yeah what can
i do with that i can't think of a story
so i told my old man and we were on a
walk in the hills in scotland
and we thought i wonder if there's
something else we could do with it could
we
come at it in a different angle so we
started
dreaming up this idea is you start with
the idea which is like a little piece of
grit
yeah and then you have to kind of
pearlize the grit over many years with
draft after draft after draft you know
but the idea was good and it lasted um i
thought i might
might as well start at the beginning
since we're talking about writing
and um i think that it's very
interesting where
writing comes from where your
relationship with words comes from and i
think mine comes
yes from reading of course but from my
father who wrote the magic roundabout
as a little girl i watched i stood at
his feet watching him just sitting there
with his headphones on
with this old machine for hours and
hours and hours on is that how he
scripted it
and that was how he scripted it he just
watched the pictures and made things up
because which if you think about it
screenplay writing is same thing only
the other way around
um but he also taught me something else
about it which i'm sure relates to
things we're going to talk about later
which was that he was writing things for
children
ostensibly these were and he made no
concession to that
whatsoever he said children are just
people who simply haven't lived
as long as we have so there is no need
or reason to talk down to them
as though they are from another planet
so i would
i grew up with that and like alan
bennett who grew up with a father who
would chase a dog out of his butcher's
shop with the words get out of here you
filthy lamppost smelling article
um you understand where it all comes
from and it's interesting
if the stage directions are very well
written i'm much more likely to take the
writer seriously
if the stage directions are lazy or
banal
then i get bored very quickly i make my
stage directions as funny as i can i put
gags into my stage directions i love
funny stage directions
they need to be not long especially if
you're reading a script and i think for
screenwriters if if you're thinking that
some producer is going to be reading it
they won't read stage direction so make
them short and snappy to what extent
do you bring your actors antennae
to writing or are the two different
elements of the same journey
well i think i bring them all the time i
mean you saw
me that you were in the room muttering
to myself
so i will tend to act all the roles i
will tend to try not to write
something that i think can't be said
that i can't be spoken i mean i
when i'm learning when you learn as an
actor god almighty
when you're trying to learn bad writing
forget it you just can't learn bad
writing it's just
impossible but good writing
it just goes into your system
it's such a joy to learn good writing
and
such a pain it's awful learning bad
right sometimes you have to you don't
we don't always get to do wonderful
things and what we want to do that's not
that's not what this job is like what
life is like
but but when it's good my gosh is
you're so grateful
you